io questa sera vi parlerò di lavoro
organizzazione del Lavoro parole che
usiamo per parlare di lavoro
tema un po' più noioso degli altri ma
speriamo di cavarcela Allora cominciamo
con un salto indietro
allora un salto di
una generazione e mezza cioè Partiamo
dalla generazione dei miei genitori per
la generazione dei miei genitori
parlando di mondo del lavoro della
produzione le aziende di riferimento
erano le aziende automobilistiche
aziende che dettavano anche le regole
dell'organizzazione del lavoro un po'
più in generale per chi ha qualche
ricordo di studi fatti c'è un signore
Friedrich Taylor un ingegnere americano
che ha inventato questo metodo
l'organizzazione scientifica del lavoro
che poi è stata implementata nella Ford
per cui noi parliamo di fordismo qualche
decennio dopo e passiamo invece
dall'America al Giappone e rendiamo la
Toyota col toyotismo un metodo di
organizzazione del lavoro che era basato
su alcune parole stasera parliamo di
parole e alcuni concetti li vedete lì
gerarchia razionalizzazione efficienza
produttività standardizzazione queste
logiche sono nate nelle aziende
automobilistiche Ma poi di fatto sono
andate per sgocciolamento in altre
aziende in altri settori in altre
organizzazioni se ci pensiamo un po'
anche l'università mantiene qualche
tratto
standardizziamo i corsi sulla base dei
crediti che cumuliamo per arrivare alla
fine al prodotto finale e tanto
desiderato salto in avanti di una
generazione arriviamo alla mia
generazione per la mia generazione le
aziende di riferimento sono aziende in
cui il prodotto conta poco relativamente
poco conta di più Il Brand e contando di
più Il Brand si cambia tutta
l'organizzazione del lavoro perché la
produzione viene delocalizzata viene
delocalizzata in particolare in paese a
basso costo del lavoro e invece nella
casa madre viene mantenuto il cosiddetto
Core business viene mantenuto il design
viene mantenuto il marketing e quindi si
costruisce un'organizzazione a con dei
nodi che mantengono dei legami Al centro
c'è il logo pensate alla famosa azienda
di cui non posso fare nome non lo farò
Però vediamo se l'ha Indovinate la
famosa azienda che era presentata da un
logo che ha la forma di un'ala l'ala
della dea greca della Vittoria da cui
questa azienda di cui non farò il nome
prende appunto la denominazione Allora
il centro è tutto lì il centro è il
brandy il nome il logo da qui nasce
anche tutta la contessazione contro i
loghi La mia generazione
ha contestato una parte della mia
generazione a contestato i loghi parole
chiave di questa organizzazione rete
sono diverse sono basate un po' più
sull'interdipendenza c'è molta
attenzione appunto a questa idea di
legame a Come mantenere anche il legame
per esempio c'è tutta una riflessione
molto interessante la fiducia allora
organizzazione rete nata in questa
aziende prevalentemente multinazionali
di nuovo Anche queste sgocciolano e
vanno in altri settori e vanno in altre
aziende e vanno in altre organizzazioni
se siete parte non so di una
associazione di volontariato
un'associazione culturale
un'associazione sportiva è molto
probabile che la vostra associazione sia
parte di una rete e che le logiche che
sono state studiate dai colleghi che
hanno studiato questi modelli di
organizzazione del lavoro si possono
applicare anche a questi mondi
totalmente distanti
e oggi
per la vostra generazione Quali sono le
aziende di riferimento Qual è il modello
organizzativo di riferimento Quali sono
le aziende che stanno cambiando il modo
in cui si organizza il lavoro e lo
stanno facendo all'interno delle loro
aziende ma forse stanno introducendo
delle logiche che come è successo in
passato potrebbero non lo sappiamo
ancora sgocciolare altrove andare in
altri settori andare un altro
organizzazione andare in altri contesti
in altre sfere sociali 3 secondi per
pensare a un'azienda Uno due tre non
rispondete non c'è tempo però sono
pronta a scommettere che l'azienda a cui
avete pensato è una di quelle che
chiamiamo aziende piattaforme
Che cosa sono le aziende piattaforme
sono aziende che sono nate da pochissimo
Tra l'altro ma sono diventate così
pervasive che nella nostra quotidianità
Se voi ci pensate probabilmente da
quando vi siete svegliati stamattina ad
ora avete usufruito in qualche modo di
alcune servizi forniti da aziende
piattaforme sono anche le aziende Oggi
più rilevanti in termini per esempio di
capitalizzazione finanziaria quindi sono
aziende che sono importanti veramente da
tanti punti di vista ma sono importanti
anche per l'organizzazione del lavoro a
questa domanda stiamo cercando di
rispondere con la nostra ricerca in
progress quindi
Lavoriamo insieme e ragioniamo insieme
se questa ipotesi possa tenere oppure no
e lo facciamo di nuovo a partire da
parole chiavi prima parola Beh facile
piattaforma
parola centrale in questa riflessione la
prima domanda che ci facciamo però è
qual è la forma della piattaforma Allora
per modelli precedenti c'è sempre
un'immagine una metafora che viene
utilizzata per raccontare il modello di
organizzazione del lavoro per
l'organizzazione scientifica del lavoro
a piramide per l'organizzazione a rete
la rete e per la piattaforma Qual è la
forma della piattaforma allora un
collega ha proposto di usare queste
immagine per rappresentare Le
piattaforme per chi ha studiato
matematica forse sono familiare è il
nastro di mobius la striscia di mobius
Qual è la caratteristica di questa
striscia immaginate qualcuno che ci
cammini sopra non ha né un dentro né un
fuori e questo è un aspetto interessante
delle piattaforme perché
nell'organizzazione tradizionale o se
dentro se è fuori o si lavora per
quell'organizzazione non si lavora per
quella organizzazione nelle aziende
piattaforma
tutti siamo
utenti al tempo stesso produciamo dei
servizi per quelle stesse piattaforme e
siamo dentro la logica di quella
piattaforma rispettiamo le regole di
quella piattaforma ma senza essere parte
dell'organizzazione e quindi c'è questa
gioco di confini che si muovono in
continuazione che diventa un elemento
importante anche per definire capire Le
piattaforme
abbiamo nel tempo usato anche delle
parole sbagliate per studiare Le
piattaforme abbiamo usato tantissimo la
parola disintermediazione è una parola
sbagliata perché perché la piattaforma è
intermedia la piattaforma stabilisce le
regole non possiamo parlare di
disintermediazione quando c'è una forma
organizzativa così importante nel
dettare le regole però è vero che
funziona in modo diverso un esempio Le
piattaforme Generalmente sono aperte
si può entrare facilmente non ci sono
grosse barriere all'accesso questo offre
incredibile opportunità crea anche a
volte qualche problema e d'ora in poi
nel prossimi minuti vi riporterò qualche
estratto dalle interviste che ho fatto
al lavoratore di piattaforme in questo
caso a un manager di piattaforma di
nuovo le parole diamo voce diamo
ascoltiamo direttamente le parole degli
intervistati Allora c'è questo manager
di una piattaforma per produzione di
contenuti digitali che durante
un'intervista mi ha detto Ma qualsiasi
persona che voglia scrivere insomma per
noi può registrarsi sulla piattaforma e
appunto non deve essere per forza un
giornalista o un redattore di
professione basta entrare in piattaforma
e scrivere vuoi fare un logo per
un'azienda Beh non c'è bisogno che tu
sia un designer entra in piattaforma e
fai il logo capite le ambiguità che si
possono creare a partire da questa
logica aperta
seconda parola
algoritmo o meglio
Management algoritmico avrete forse
sentito la frase il tuo capo è un
algoritmo
diciamo quando diciamo che il capo è un
algoritmo gli algoritmi nelle
piattaforme svolgono tante funzioni
diverse
si occupano a volte di organizzare il
lavoro a volte di fare matching a volte
di controllare a volte di sorvegliare il
lavoro svolgono veramente tante funzioni
bisogna stare attenti però perché a
volte queste funzioni non le svolgono
direttamente Le piattaforme Ma le fanno
svolgere a noi poi su questo torneremo
c'è un dato però vi raccontavo prima
dell'organizzazione scientifica del
Lavoro l'organizzazione scientifica del
lavoro ha creato i manager
il modello piattaforma potrebbe
distruggerle potrebbe eliminare questa
figura E perché perché le funzioni che
tradizionalmente sono state svolte
prevalentemente dal Middle Management
Quindi da un livello intermedio oggi
appunto vengono in parte incorporate
dall'algoritmo in parte delegate a nuove
figure c'è un'altra caratteristica del
management algoritmico che è molto
importante organizzazione scientifica
del Lavoro le regole poteva le regole
proprio di organizzazione del Lavoro
potevano essere dure disumane Ma erano
chiare chi entrava a lavorare in Quelle
aziende sapeva benissimo Quali regole
doveva rispettare oggi le norme delle
piattaforme spesso sono poche non si
conoscono e le persone che usano Le
piattaforme non conoscono le regole del
gioco a cui stanno giocando e Le
piattaforme fanno questo operazione che
viene definita di recoading cambiano in
continuazione le regole proprio per Non
renderle trasparenti
Qui c'è una bella ricerca che ha fatto
Francesco Bonifacio e Francesco ha fatto
il Rider per un po' per qualche mese e
ha raccolto le testimonianze di altri
Rider e c'è un Rider che gli ha detto
questa questa cosa l'applicazione l'app
non fa sempre bene i suoi conti ti sale
il punteggio il giorno dopo ti scende
cioè c'è un po' un meccanismo che
ufficialmente sembra che loro dicono che
sia trasparente intuibile Però in realtà
non è intuibile da nessuno a volte non
hanno proprio spiegazioni Anche se le
chiedi non ti sanno neanche spiegare
loro ti dicono una qualsiasi cosa per
tenerti buono ti dicono è l'algoritmo
terza parola se sto tenendo bene i conti
il profilo digitale quando entriamo in
piattaforma tutti noi creiamo il nostro
profilo Creiamo un profilo che ci
racconta ci rappresenta ma il tempo
stesso dobbiamo anche selezionare capire
che cosa dire di noi cosa comunicare in
quel contesto in quel in quella sfera
sociale che così particolare e pensate
alle implicazioni quando una persona
deve costruire un profilo per lavorare
non per interagire con gli amici che
cosa racconto che cosa non racconto
questa è una baby sitter che ho
intervistato che mi dice prima con
riferimento quando faceva la baby-sitter
tramite Passaparola non mi venivano
chieste le mie competenze serviva
semplicemente qualcuno che tenesse una
bambina invece adesso ci ho fatto più
attenzione ho scritto cose vere ma che
potessero attirare le persone nel
contesto di prima non avrei chiesto a
mia madre di farmi pubblicità perché
studio tante lingue perché sono
possibile eccetera non serviva Non serve
non serviva era una questione di
conoscenze invece ora ci ho dovuto
pensare come mi descrivere è uno
sconosciuto Io ho fatto interviste a
baby sitter ho fatto interviste a
persone che fanno pulizie domestiche
pulizia appunto nelle case vanno nelle
case a fare pulizie che dimostrano di
essere capaci di fare personal branding
meglio degli influencer o dei vip Perché
Perché ne hanno bisogno per lavorare
Ecco le scelte che fanno quotidianamente
sono
interessanti e possono cambiare anche la
loro quotidianità ho intervistato una
ragazza di 23 anni che fa pulizie cioè
tramite una piattaforma per cui si
prenota qualcuno che venga in casa a
pulire i vetri a pulire la casa e lei mi
ha raccontato di aver scelto una
piattaforma che le permettesse di non
mettere la fotografia perché Perché è
giovane di bell'aspetto e non voleva
attrarre l'attenzione indesiderate Masca
servirebbe qualcuno pensate che scelte
difficili è lo stesso modo intervistato
una 55enne che lavora attraverso la
stessa piattaforma che mi ha detto Ho
scelto questa piattaforma perché possono
metterla fotografia perché ho 55 anni
sai potrebbero non selezionarmi pensando
che io sia troppo anziana per fare un
lavoro che fisicamente faticoso quante
cose decidiamo di dire quante cose
decidiamo di non dire e quante cose gli
altri dicono di noi arriviamo all'ultima
parola
reputazione Perché sulle piattaforme non
c'è solo la nostra autodistruzione ci
sono anche i racconti che gli altri
fanno di noi
c'è tutto in passato la reputazione
sempre stata importante Però veniva
tipicamente dietro le nostre spalle si è
sempre parlato di tutti e il passaparola
rispetto alla reputazione è sempre stato
importante in ambito professionale Ora
però accade online e questo cambia tutta
la dinamica
e anche qui ci sono degli aspetti
interessanti vi leggo subito una
citazione di un pediatra e un
allergologo che ho intervistato che usa
una piattaforma per fare consulenze
mediche che mi dice
parlando appunto del sistema
reputazionale trovo che può andar bene
per fare una recensione su una di un
acquisto su Amazon secondo me va meno
bene per fare la recensione di una
prestazione medica perché spesso le
recensioni sono basate sulla sfera
emotiva legata alla simpatia del medico
che non corrisponde per forza la sua
capacità diagnostica ci sono dei medici
piacioni come diciamo a Roma il medico
piacione può avere un'ottima recensione
ed essere un pessimo medico
Se dovete scegliere un medico preferite
il medico piacione o il medico con
capacità diagnostica ovviamente tutte e
due cioè ovviamente tutte e due tutti
Vorremmo avere un medico capace di fare
il suo lavoro al tempo stesso capace di
entrare in relazione con noi
cosa succede però quando ci muoviamo su
sistemi in cui il sistema di riferimento
cosiddetto profano Quindi la valutazione
da parte di persone che non hanno le
competenze tecniche per valutare un
professionista Pesa di più e a volte
sostituisce la competenza esperta questo
è evidente che cambia tantissimo le
regole del gioco soprattutto se queste
logiche come stiamo ipotizzando
potrebbero fuoriuscire dalla piattaforma
e andare a interessare tutte le
organizzazioni del lavoro o tante
organizzazioni del lavoro
Ultima Parola di questa serata
è una parola in inglese
Diletta saprebbe proprio pronunciarla
meglio di me che è emersa durante la
pandemia forse L'avete sentita Great
grandi dimissioni durante la pandemia
quello che è successo è che tante
persone hanno lasciato loro posto di
lavoro ho ancora Quiet quitting stanno
ancora lì fanno il minimo indispensabile
Senza implicarsi troppo nel mondo del
lavoro allora noi stiamo facendo tante
riflessioni su questo fenomeno che è
interessante e finora Però è stato
trattato spesso in modo sbagliato Ci
sono delle persone che lasciano il
lavoro due elementi tutta l'attenzione
oggi è sulle persone che lasciano il
lavoro spesso tra l'altro queste persone
sono giovani e allora scattano tutti
quei meccanismi che ci ha raccontato
benissimo benedette quindi non c'è
bisogno di ripeterlo perché l'ha fatto
lei meglio di me quel giudizio
generazionale
I giovani non hanno voglia di lavorare
potrebbe finire lì la riflessione non
può portaremmo a casa nulla l'altra
possibilità invece è provare a spostare
il fuoco e andare a vedere l'altro pezzo
non i giovani che lasciano il lavoro Ma
che lavoro stanno lasciando E allora su
questo si aprono grandi possibilità
soprattutto se ragioniamo in termini di
organizzazione del lavoro perché quello
è uno spazio su cui si può intervenire e
Allora potremmo andare a diventare nuovi
Taylor che però costruiscono
un'organizzazione del lavoro che mette
al centro il benessere dei lavoratori e
che permetta a tutti noi giovani e non
di lavorare meglio grazie
[Applauso]